the days of open door policy on school
campuses are long gone for ccsd the kids
will all get on campus and then you know
we lock our doors
up and then visitors in and out
will be going through the single point
of entry superintendent dr jesus jarrah
leading the press conference about the
new changes coming after several violent
incidents last year in schools from
fights to staff being attacked by
students the safety
of our students and our staff is of the
utmost priority for me this year the
school district is piloting an instant
alert system allowing staff to be in
direct contact with police in case of an
emergency every officer is ready to
respond quickly and professionally
to any emergency
on our campuses the school district and
police are reassuring parents students
and staff that it's different here as
the lack of response during the school
shooting in uvalde texas is weighing on
many our advanced training at metro
takes a hard look at it we recreate it
we review our policies and we ensure
that we would not have the same failures
another critical part of their safety
plan is installing nine security cameras
and school buses but for the first day
of school sixty percent of the buses
will have them ready the six million
dollar project will go into nineteen
hundred school buses the new camera
systems will have live look-in
and real-time surveillance capabilities
we asked some parents how they are
feeling with the new changes i do like
the camera idea there's 2 000 kids that
go to my daughter's high school and
there's no way that admins can know
every single parent that should be
coming onto campus and know that if
you're safe or not so i understand the
need for more safety